los militares a las calles después de un
mes de protestas continuadas en colombia
contra el gobierno de iván duque el
presidente amplió la asistencia militar
para controlar la crisis que atraviesa
el país una figura que ya había usado
para cali el epicentro de las
manifestaciones a principios de mayo y
que en la madrugada del sábado extendió
a ocho departamentos más del país y 13
municipios
eso implica que se desplegará el
ejército en estas regiones para apoyar a
la policía en sus tareas de control del
orden público
además duque advirtió a las autoridades
locales que recibirán sanciones si no
aceptan la presencia del ejército en las
calles la asistencia militar está
contemplada en el código de policía de
2016 y se trata de una medida
excepcional es el instrumento legal que
puede aplicarse cuando hechos de grave
alteración de la seguridad y la
convivencia lo exijan o ante riesgo o
peligro inminente o para afrontar
emergencia o calamidad pública a través
del cual el presidente de la república
podrá disponer de forma temporal y
excepcional de la asistencia de la
fuerza militar
el ejército puede ayudar a proteger los
servicios esenciales las
infraestructuras públicas o la propiedad
privada en riesgo pero según las leyes
colombianas no puede intervenir en las
manifestaciones ni capturar a nadie
organizaciones internacionales como la
onu la oea y la unión europea volvieron
a insistir en el diálogo para hacer
frente a la crisis después de un mes de
protestas en las que se han acumulado
las denuncias por la brutalidad de la
fuerza pública